estamos mis dos hermanas y yo en la
oficina de un enorme hospital público yo
tenía cuatro años mis hermanas 6 y 8
y la verdad es que a esa edad ya sabía
yo entendía casi todo lo que pasa a mi
alrededor o al menos eso es lo que
sentía
pasamos ahí toda la noche
tenía cuatro años pero sabía
perfectamente por qué estábamos ahí
no había nadie más que nos cuidara
[Música]
desafortunadamente tampoco teníamos
dinero para pagar una niñera pero mi
mamá tenía que trabajar porque es
enfermera y fue hacer esa noche lo que
tenía que hacer para sacarnos adelante
esa solamente es una de muchas historias
que les puedo contar acerca de mi mamá
pero hay otras también un poquito más
divertidas cuando yo no me quería
levantar en las mañanas para para ir a
la escuela porque según yo me dolía la
cabeza o me sentía mal o algo así mira
me ha orientado con un paracetamol y me
decía levántate porque cubierta se te va
a quitar y me ha llevado a la escuela
cuando yo ya no quería ir más a las
clases de béisbol porque era muy muy
malo jugando béisbol mi mamá me decía
pues ahora bajas y descritas el uniforme
porque ya me hiciste pagarlo y me
llevaba a las clases de béisbol así que
pues sí fue mi mamá fue mi mamá la que
sin darse cuenta con su ejemplo con sus
acciones me enseñó a hacer lo que tengo
que hacer para lograr lo que yo quiera
en la vida y fue precisamente esa
herramienta la que ayudó a ese niño
flaco y cabezón a lograr todo lo que lo
que se propuso en la vida
mis primeros patines los recuerdo
perfectamente eran negros con ruedas
moradas y unos proyectos amarillos con
los que te los aprietas me lo regalaron
en una navidad a los 6 años y me
encantaban me fascinaba patinar no sé
como pasaba en esos épocas pero a mis
amiguitos de la cuadra nos amanecía lo
mismo y un año bicicletas otro año patín
del pero ese año todos teníamos
patines y ahí me encantaba jugar
carreritas en la calle contra ellos me
acabé mis patines me acabé los de mi
hermana del medio me acabé también los
de mi hermana mayor
pero ojalá ojalá así de sencillo hubiera
sido encontrar mi pasión realmente en
ese momento los patines eran un juguete
más y patinar era una actividad que dejé
de hacer con el tiempo mientras crecía y
siendo un niño pasé por casi todos los
deportes fútbol natación karate béisbol
y era malísimo en todos él todos lo
único que sabía hacer bien era correr
rápido
pero afortunadamente cuando yo tengo 12
años mi mamá se entera que existe el
patinaje de velocidad y me lleva a
entrenarlo y estaba tan emocionado el
primer día de entrenamiento me llevé lo
que queda de los patines de mi hermana
mayor y tal era mi emoción que lubrica
los baleros de mis ruedas con aceite de
cocina
no es broma leche aceite de cocina mis
baleros para que según yo girará el más
rápido
seguramente a alguien le di la estima y
en el entrenamiento me prestaron algunos
patines para terminar el entrenamiento y
me encantó me enamoré me enamoré del
deporte me enamoré del dolor de piernas
de el aire en mi cara y supe desde ese
momento que yo quería regresar a patinar
ese y muchos días más más de mi vida
todo esto pasó en hermosillo ahí es
donde yo empecé a patinar y unos años
después también tendremos y yo me
adentré hacer alto rendimiento a mí me
encanta como si yo hay muy buena comida
muy buena carne tortillas de harina
pero desafortunadamente también hay
personas muy machistas y personas con la
mente muy cerrada no se imaginan lo
difícil que fue para mí y también para
el resto del equipo de patinaje empezar
a entrenar con este tránsito de lycra
que usamos para patinar
todo mundo está acostumbrado a ver a los
clavadistas con su traje de baño los
gimnastas e incluso los ciclistas con
uniformes parecidos a los de nosotros
pero nadie había visto antes a un
patinador que necesite un informe que
parece pijama pegadita donde muy poco se
deja la imaginación
entonces las burlas las miradas de las
personas que pasaban al lado de la pista
fue el primer obstáculo que yo tuve que
superar dentro del patinaje como lo
superé ignorándolos yo en ese momento
comprendí que así como estaban
acostumbrados a ver a los clavadistas
seguramente unos años después iban a
estar acostumbrados a ver a los
patinadores con su uniforme de lycra y
desde ahí me di cuenta que me estaba
comenzando a atrever a ser diferente
cuando estás completamente adolorido y
cansado por el entrenamiento que te
duele desde la punta del pie hasta la
frente cada músculo de tu cuerpo la
mente te puede llegar a traicionar
cuando estás queriendo levantar en las
mañanas para ir a entrenar seguramente
ustedes también les ha pasado para su
trabajo o lo que tengan que hacer en las
mañanas incluso puede llegar a pensar
que está mal lo que estás haciendo que
estás enfermo que tienes que dormir más
y ahí es cuando me acuerdo de las
palabras de mi mamá
levántate jorge libertad se te quita
el cansancio no se te quita
desgraciadamente
pero así así me levanto a entrenar todos
los días de hacer lo que tengo que hacer
con todo el dolor de mi alma y el dolor
de todo mi cuerpo y cuando haces eso lo
que tampoco se te quita es la
satisfacción de haber hecho todas tus
obligaciones al final del día y te das
cuenta al final de ese día que estás un
paso más cerca de tus objetivos a la
meta no se llega espontáneamente a la
meta se llega todos los días con tus
decisiones diarias
en el 2009
me fui a vivir a guadalajara
una ciudad muy diferente al museo mucho
más grande
no había tortillas de harina pero si
teníamos mucho mejor clima y me fui a
guadalajara porque mi gran objetivo de
ese momento era los juegos panamericanos
de guadalajara en el 2011 pero ahora
imagínense lo que sufre un foráneo
deportista
tenemos que intentar comer bien así que
nada de quesadillas nada de pan blanco
para sandwich
pero que lo peor es que tenemos lo más
difícil de todas que tenemos que tener
comida en el refri
no nos podemos desvelar tenemos que
entrenar al día siguiente
pero nada nada de esto de todo lo que
sufrí siendo un foráneo deportista me
hizo siquiera pensar en desistir o tirar
la toalla de lo que yo tenía en mi mente
afortunadamente pude ser parte de la
selección nacional eso no era lo más
complicado lo más complicado era lograr
una buena participación porque en
américa competimos contra potencias
mundiales del patinaje colombia
venezuela chile argentina así que pensar
si quieren una medalla eran realmente
palabras mayores
[Música]
afortunadamente mi preparación para esos
juegos fue muy muy buena buenísima y
estaba en un muy buen momento deportivo
y la ansiedad que yo tenía por competir
y por demostrar por demostrar lo que yo
traía era muy grande llegué el día de la
competencia
éramos sede
las gradas llenas llenas de periodistas
de familiares de directivos
y yo hice un desastre de carrera
todos los errores que pude haber
cometido los hice todos
una tarde muy difícil para mí
no quería saber absolutamente nada del
patinaje quería que me tragara la tierra
y que nunca nunca más una para una pista
me fui en solar un baño no quiere dar
entrevistas no quería fotos y fue una
tarde muy difícil porque al mismo tiempo
mi mejor amiga del alma del patinaje y
de la vida estaba haciendo historia para
el patinaje mexicano estaba ganando la
primera medalla en unos juegos
panamericanos para el patinaje de
velocidad y yo no pude estar con ella no
puede siquiera celebrarlo
de lo mal de lo mal que me sentía
pasaron los días en los que medite pensé
mucho llore volvía a llorar
y tomé la mejor decisión de mi vida
decidir no retirarme me di cuenta que
donde yo pensaba que podía ser el final
apenas apenas era el comienzo
en mi vida en toda mi carrera deportiva
tampoco faltaron los maestros los
maestros de la escuela que se atrevieron
a aconsejar me desde su posición desde
su realidad que para qué pátinas si no
es fútbol del patinaje no vas a vivir
solamente el estudio te garantiza una
vida digna y una vida próspera etcétera
muchos etcéteras
incluso mi primer entrenador dijo en
alguna ocasión que yo nunca iba a poder
ganar una medalla porque no era lo
suficientemente talentoso imagínese
y ya estando grande a los 22 años se
acerca se acerca una persona muy
influyente en el deporte nacional en ese
momento a decirme despectivamente que ya
mejor me retirara y que me pusiera a
entrenar niños como si eso fuera algo
malo y que dejara de internar el
patinaje comprendí comprendí que hay
siempre siempre hay voces externas
te dan su opinión e intentan decirte que
hacer algunas lo van a hacer desde su
realidad desde su perspectiva queriendo
lo mejor para ti y queriendo tu
bienestar como mis maestros por ejemplo
pero también hay otras
que lo van a hacer para verte caer para
verte desistir simplemente porque ellos
no tuvieron el valor de vivir su propia
vida o de trazar su propio camino por lo
menos tomar un camino alterno al ya
transitado
pero lo importante aquí es que vos es la
que tú escuchas y sobre todo que te
estás diciendo tú a ti mismo qué mensaje
le estás mandando primeramente a tu
mente a tu cuerpo a tus músculos cada
día de tu vida eso es lo importante y en
el camino aprendí a que todo lo que yo
decidía tenía un factor clave en mi vida
en el resultado la derrota del 2011 me
enseñó
a hacer también lo que no me gusta hacer
que es lo más difícil es el primer paso
para aprender a hacer lo que tienes que
hacer y es el más difícil de todos
aprendí a no posponer cinco minutos más
la alarma en las mañanas porque sabía
que si lo hacía podía llegar tarde no
calentaba bien en el entrenamiento y me
podía lesionar aprendí a comer lo que
necesito comer no nomás lo que se me
antoja ni siquiera lo que se me antoja
porque si no lo hacía comprendí que no
iba a aumentar de masa muscular por lo
tanto no iba a poder ser más fuerte
y lo más importante de la derrota del
2011 es que me hizo una persona
consciente y cuando eres una persona
consciente es mucho más difícil que
tomes decisiones malas para ti
en toronto cuatro años después la
revancha
no nada más gane una medalla
en mi prueba favorita quedan los 200
metros sino que también gane una segunda
medalla en la prueba de 500 metros que
era una prueba super difícil para mí en
ese momento y nunca imaginé ganar una
medalla en esa prueba en esos juegos así
que estaba muy emocionado y muy contento
motivado sobre todo para seguir haciendo
las cosas bien para seguir tomando
decisiones buenas para mí
al siguiente año en el 2016
voy al campeonato del mundo en nanjing
china
mi décimo campeonato del mundo un camino
muy largo en el patinaje así que ya sr
y desde el principio del campeonato yo
sabía que tenía posibilidades tal vez de
ganar alguna medalla o pasar a la final
de los 100 metros carriles entonces yo
desde el primer día me enfoqué para ese
día y esa prueba desde que conocí el
escenario en el que iba a participar
nunca dejé de visualizar me dando lo
mejor de mí en ese lugar llegó el día
tan esperado
fui pasando clasificando ronda por ronda
cuartos de final semifinal final para la
final hago mi calentamiento me preparo
pongo ruedas nuevas en es patines
aprieto todos los tornillos que todo
esté en orden
pongo mi uniforme mis números mi casco
me paro en la línea de salida
tengo a un espanyol enseguida de mí un
alemán en el extremo somos los tres
finalistas los tres hombres más rápidos
del mundo y pasó lo que a continuación
van a ver
[Aplausos]
[Música]
la carrera duró nueve segundos con 82
centésimas pero yo sentí que fueron como
10 minutos se me hizo eterna y cuando
cruzó la meta y me doy cuenta que soy
campeón del mundo lo primero que se me
vino a la mente fueron todas las cosas
que tuve que pasar para estar en ese
lugar en ese momento con esas
condiciones los 5 minutos que no me
dormí más la comida que se me antojaba
que nunca me comí las derrotas las
tristezas la gente que creyó en mí la
gente que no creyó en mí el 2011
como cuando dicen que te vas a morir y
que te pasas toda tu vida por tu mente
en un segundo más o menos así fue pero
yo no me estaba muriendo yo me di cuenta
que estaba haciendo mi sueño realidad
cada día de mi vida durante todos esos
años
en lima 2019 también gané un par de
medallas para méxico que me hicieron
sentir muy muy diferente en lima que me
dice me convertí en la mejor versión de
mí mismo y no precisamente por las
medallas
en lima 2019 comprendí que no importa no
importa todas las medallas que ganes si
no estás haciendo algo por tu país por
tu gente por dejar un mensaje no importa
si eres campeón del mundo lo que importa
es que hagas un bien a todos los demás y
aprovechar esa posición en lima 2019
empecé a vivir una vida plena para mí en
toda la extensión de lo que signifique
esa frase y comprendí que no va a haber
ninguna medalla que me haga sentir más
feliz más orgulloso de ser mexicano pero
sobre todo de ser yo de ser jorge
no hay una fórmula mágica todos somos
distintos cada piedad es única pero lo
que sí necesitamos hacer todos para
cumplir nuestros objetivos es
levantarnos a hacerlo sin pensar mucho
levántate y hazlo haz lo que tengas que
hacer
y una vez arriba toma decisiones durante
tu día que te acerquen a tu objetivo
las derrotas y las tristezas también son
parte del éxito aprende a disfrutarlas
porque es parte de tu vida es lo que
estás sintiendo en ese momento pero
sobre todo aprende a superarlas
cuál es tu sueño
eso qué estás pensando en este momento
no importa no importa si los demás no
creen en ti no importa si no lo
descubriste en un regalo de navidad
desde niño lo que importa es que tú
creas en ti lo que importa es que tu
sueño sea tan pero tan real dentro de ti
que lo sientas que lo vivas para que te
haga levantarte todas las mañanas hacer
lo que tienes que hacer sin importar
cómo te sientas
creer y crear
en el tiempo presente de la primera
persona se conjugan igual yo creo
gracias
[Aplausos]